sur le site de general electric ce matin
trois députés fabien roussel du parti
communiste bastien la chaux des insoumis
et olivier marleix des républicains tous
ont fait partie de la commission d'
enquête parlementaire sur le rachat
d'alstom par ji objectifs de la journée
rencontrer les syndicats pour tenter une
sortie de crise balayés l'éventail des
solutions envisageables pour éviter ici
la suppression d'un millier d'emplois
ça va être de faire une mise en demeure
auprès du ministre de l'économie de
faire usage de ses pouvoirs pour
convoquer notamment il ya dans les
accords 2014 était prévu un comité de
suivi des engagements donc de réunir de
façon exceptionnelle ce comité de suivi
et demander des comptes et general
electric
il serait impensable que l'état puisse
un jour homologué plan social a fortiori
un plan social unilatérale sans avoir
vérifié que ce plan social est conforme
ou pas aux au respect des intérêts
nationaux qu'il avait identifiés pour
cela l'intersyndicale de ji s'organise
et constitue petit à petit un collectif
s'entoure d'allier divers pour pouvoir
peser face à la direction
ici on évoque même l'hypothèse d'un
rachat du site par l'état on va
réfléchir
c'est une proposition qui est faite en
fonction des tendances politiques
on va plus est plus orienté vers une
nationalisation en tout état de cause ce
qui ressort de
de cette réflexion de la discussion
c'est qu'il faut que la france se
redonne d'un champion industriel à
l'envergure internationale comme l'était
alstom selon les élus syndicaux et
certains députés
general electric pourrait être vendeur
d'une partie de ses activités sur
belfort
si rien n'est fait d'ici quelques mois
les premières lettres de licenciement
seront envoyées aux salariés